memoir from former Secretary of State
Madeleine Albright this past Friday she
sat down with Sam Donaldson of ABC News
at the national press club in washington
DC this program lasts an hour good
afternoon and welcome to the National
Press Club my name is Eleanor Herman and
I am a member of the club's book and
author committee first of all I'd like
to ask all of you to please turn off
your cell phones and pagers we extend
today a hearty welcome to secretary
Madeleine Albright author of Madam
Secretary copies of the book are
available for purchase right outside the
door here and each sale benefits the
club's library and before we get started
I would like to mention some upcoming
book and author events here at the
National Press Club the winner of the
James Beard Award for Best Chef in New
York City Marcus Samuelsson will join us
for a book wrap wine dinner on Thursday
October 7th to discuss his new cookbook
aquavit australian author donna hay will
speak on saturday october 18th about her
cookbook modern classics book 2 at an
afternoon tea best-selling author
Richard North Patterson will join us for
a book wrap on Thursday October 23rd to
discuss his book balance of power
secretary Albright will be interviewed
by sam donaldson and then we will open
up the floor for discussions of
questions so we'll be coming around with
to collect the question cards if any
occurred to you during the interview now
after the interview we will have the
book signing at that table right over
there Oscar Wilde once said anybody can
make history only a great man can write
it well Madeleine Albright is now in a
position to correct Oscar Wilde for not
only has she made history but this great
woman has now written history secretary
Albright was the 64th secretary of state
of the United States the first one
secretary asst government born into an
Eastern Europe convulsed by war and the
Holocaust it is perhaps fitting that on
secretary Albright swatch NATO was
expanded to include Eastern European
nations healing the rift that 60 years
earlier had torn apart her native land
according to Ralph Waldo Emerson there
is no history only biographies and how
much more revealing is an autobiography
a memoir bringing to life not only the
experiences but the private thoughts and
feelings of the famous and the powerful
Madam Secretary explores Madeleine
Albright's childhood and immigration her
more traditional role as wife and mother
of three daughters her painful divorce
and her fascinating years in politics
she gives us lively candid impressions
of slobodan milosevic Ariel Sharon
Yasser Arafat and President Clinton
indeed her years in office were pivotal
and saw the horrors of Kosovo the
daunting challenges of bringing peace to
the Middle East the defining of a
post-cold war relationship with Russia
and NAT last but not least Monica
Lewinsky throughout most of her career
secretary Albright found herself the
only woman at the table and as such had
to work extra hard to make her voice
heard we are delighted to have her here
with us today and as I mentioned Sam
Donaldson will be conducting the
interview Sam a familiar face in every
American's living room has been with ABC
News for 36 years has served two
appointments as chief White House
correspondent and currently hosts the
Sam Donaldson show live in America a
daily news talk radio program Sam we are
honored to have you with us today
Dean Acheson once observed that the
prerequisite to be Secretary of State
was to be boring where did you go wrong
well I decided that it was much more fun
to be myself and tell it like it is and
be a woman and do it my way well of
course the fact that you're here is
amazing your name wasn't Madeline was
mad Lanka and you were born in what was
then czechoslovakia and and your parents
had to flee what the Nazis to begin with
yes and I actually was my name was Maria
Jana which is Mary Jane but my
grandmother there was a play in Prague
at the time believe it or not called
Madeline in the brick factory and she
thought Madeline was a good name and
that's how it all started out my father
was a Czechoslovakia Matt and when the
Nazis invaded in March 1939 his career
ended and so he went to London and
joined the government the Czechoslovak
government in exile and there are some
things that distinguish us because we're
about the same age but what it really
makes me different from you as I lived
through World War two I was in London
during the bombing and then when the war
ended my father became ambassador to
Yugoslavia and then the Communists took
over and we came to the United States
and so in many ways I am blessed to have
been able to come to America but we did
have to leave the place where we came
from we all know that when you became
Secretary of State you learned for the
first time something about your ancestry
you learned that your grandparents had
been killed in a nazi extermination camp
and you learned that you had a jewish
background that's right and i try to
separate the two things in my own mind
because they're very different and i
wrote a chapter about this and was as
frank and honest as I could have been
about all of it I was very interested
and excited to learn about my Jewish
background because I already thought I
had a very rich background and that
added to the tapestry what was
wrenching was when I found out that my
grandparents had died in the
concentration camp I obviously always
knew about the Holocaust and had in fact
gone to many Holocaust memorials but
didn't realize that I was personally
connected to it and the really difficult
thing was that I learned all this just
as I was becoming Secretary of State and
everybody was watching to see if a woman
could do the job and I had to deal with
this very personal pain in a very public
way and some people were suspicious that
thought you well that she actually knew
and sort of cross-examined you sort of
it was a these jackals of the press you
know how they are it was actually very
hard because I I could understand why
people would be critical of me but what
hurt me the most where people were very
critical of my father and thought that
he had lied or was a fraud and and I
think this becomes evident in the book I
adored my father and he was a very the
key figure in my life and he wasn't
around to defend himself I try to
explain why it is I never asked because
I had a complete story of my life and if
you have no reason to ask questions
there were no holes or anything so I
didn't ask and so I know people didn't
believe me and I hope very much that the
book explains what I knew and when I
knew it family moved to Colorado and
again for years it was the unlikely that
we were going to hear of you on the
national scene you got married and you
were married to Joe all right for how
many years 23 years and then what
happened you're right it's the worst day
in your life well it just was was a very
bad day in Washington generally January
thirteen to nineteen eighty-two was the
day of the air Florida crash and an
incredible snow and my then husband came
back from a trip and SAT me down in our
living room and said our marriage is
dead and for me that was an incredible
shock because I thought that I was
married to the most wonderful man who
was supportive very much of what I was
doing but he evidently
they had other ideas you say in the book
that you didn't believe him at first you
thought it was just kidding or there was
some bad play here well it was like a
grade B movie I must say and I actually
having had no suspicions did make up
what i call the brain tumor theory which
was that he was trying to spare us all
of terrible pain and decided that he
would leave because he didn't want us to
all suffer that obviously was not true
and it was a very very hard time and the
reason that I write about it as honestly
as I do and it wasn't an easy chapter to
write is that I think there are a lot of
people men and women who go through very
hard divorces and kind of think it's all
over and life will never be good and for
me it turned out I pulled myself
together and ended up in a pretty good
place well I've dwell on it in some time
now because you had escaped the Nazis
can't escape the Soviets here you were
in a marriage you thought was very good
and you fell apart after all of that you
might be excused if you just thought
well I'll just drop out well I always
have believed that it is possible to
make a difference that is something that
my father really taught me and I was
given many opportunities and at the
beginning I really wanted to have
something to do because I needed to fill
my time my kids were grown up and I just
kept volunteering and doing more things
I was always available to do the job and
I worked hard and I don't believe in
just giving up I I really believe that
there is a purpose to being put on this
earth and I had huge opportunities and I
and I took them you worked hard at
foreign policies big def Brzezinski was
Jimmy Carter's a national security
adviser and he of course was what an old
professor of yours yes I mean there's so
many accidents in my life of people that
show up someplace and then show up again
somewhere else I went to Columbia where
I was getting my PhD and I say this in
the book with due respect to all my
other professors he really was the most
incredible professor teaching a course
in 90
63 about differences in communism and
then when he came to Washington as the
national security advisor I was then
working for ad muskie on Senate and
Brzezinski called me up and asked me
whether I would find him a place to live
and I said she's big I thought you were
calling to offered me a job and he said
no I'm calling to ask you to find me a
place to live but a year later he did
offer me a job and I loved working for
President Carter and him on the National
Security Council and later you advise
other Democratic candidates who must be
losing mostly losing that's right you
don't think you bore some of that
responsibility do you uh well you never
know but I I did have a bad run and the
interesting part is of all the
presidents I actually didn't work for in
their campaign bill clinton was it
because at that time i was president of
the Center for national policy which is
a an independent think tank and it was
not appropriate to help one candidate I
offered my services and that of the
think tank to everybody some took me up
and some didn't but I didn't actually
work in Bill Clinton's campaign well why
then do you think he selected you to be
the ambassador to the United Nations
well what had happened was I first met
him when he came up he was governor of
Arkansas and he had come up to Boston to
advise Michael Dukakis on debate prep
and we started talking and he as we all
know is very engaging and very smart it
then turned out that he was a graduate
of Georgetown School of Foreign Service
where I happened to be teaching and we
stayed in close contact and I think he
knew of my interest and they're not a
lot of women that were in foreign policy
at that time and I had really labored in
democratic vineyards and I knew my stuff
and so I was very glad when he appointed
me what was the high point as you saw it
of being the UN ambassador well i think
that the high point was there wasn't one
point what i found very interesting Sam
was that I was there at a time where we
were debating what it was possible for
the UN to do the UN had been paralyzed
through 50 years of the Cold War and
all of a sudden it was free to act and
we were developing how peacekeeping
operations would work where the United
States would act and so I enjoyed the
whole aspect of it I was very glad when
we were able to get a resolution on
Haiti because that was one of our major
problems and that was really my first
diplomatic success but there were some
low points that I talked about that I
feel terrible about which is Rwanda
where we were not able to get action and
obviously the tragedies in Somalia but
it was really liked being at the UN now
you say where we were not able to get
action do not think the United States
should have moved more aggressively well
I again I've tried to analyze this very
frankly I and the reason that i wrote
the section generally was to put what
was happening in rwanda into the context
of what was happening everywhere else
and as you remember the tragedy of
Mogadishu with the Black Hawk helicopter
had just happened and we were involved
in other peacekeeping operations and
there was a sense that there was an over
extension but even if we had been able
to get our forces together the facts are
that there was a volcanic explosion that
was the genocide and I think it wouldn't
have been possible to get forces there
in time but what I regret is not being
clearer about the need to have a
position that was supportive of getting
troops and I did have quite a fit in
terms of the instructions that I'd
gotten I managed to get them changed but
I wish I had been clear the way that the
Canadian commander had been you also
talk just about how you had to confront
boutros boutros-ghali who wanted another
term as secretary-general the United
States had decided he shouldn't have one
and there you had to discuss it with him
and what very frank as the diplomats a
language that's for sure and and I would
say that was a high point but I don't
like to get high points out of other
people's demise but what
happened was the boutros-ghali was a
compromise candidate when he was voted
secretary-general an agreement made by
the first Bush administration and he
promised that he would only have one
term and very shortly into that term he
began to campaign for a second term and
he really was not somebody that it was
easy for the United States to work with
I don't think he explained the policies
of the UN very well I'd really tried to
work with him and in fact had many
dinners with him in many private
meetings in one which was quite
remarkable he we were having dinner and
all of a sudden he raises his hand and
he said I've just seen a Nigerian seer
and he says there is a woman she will
betray you her name is Madeleine he
laughed well in any event he wasn't the
secretary-general after one term all
right President Clinton of course was
reelected he's going to have a second
term Warren Christopher the Secretary of
State was not going to continue in that
post and lots of speculation who would
be the secretary of state your name was
there but a lot of people didn't think I
mean after all a woman well it was a
very strange time because speculating
about things like this is you know all
too well Sam is one of Washington's
favorite games and there were other
names on the list and then somebody at
the White House I think made a major
error they said to the press that yes I
was on the list but I was second tier
and that kind of got some people's
hackles up and and I think that as I
have found out since my name actually
never was off the list other people came
and went but my name was there the whole
time and I think mostly people didn't
believe that a woman would become
Secretary of State I did not want this
to be just a women's issue because
President Clinton had already named so
many women to high-level positions that
if it was just going to be a test of
whether he was going to name a woman to
Secretary of State that wasn't a good
enough
and so I had hoped that I would be
considered on the basis of my
credentials but there was another
powerful woman in your corner the first
lady that was very important didn't hurt
did it know for sure not and what had
happened was I actually didn't know
Hilary very well before all this started
I mean before they came to the White
House I'd met her a couple of times
during the campaign and we had some
mutuality because we'd both gone to
Wellesley she's 10 years younger than I
am however and then when I was at the UN
and she began her activities
internationally she'd come up and visit
and the delegates were really impressed
with her we had lots of meetings
together and we became friends and I
think our biggest kind of collective act
was when we went to the Beijing
conference for women where she made that
incredible speech about women's rights
are human rights and human rights or
women's rights and and I think we found
that we could work together very well
and she was supportive but she writes in
her book but I don't think I would have
been Secretary of State if President
Clinton hadn't wanted me to be now
what's it like waiting by the phone I
mean whether you want to be on the
ticket in the second spot I mean whether
you want to be in the cabinet it always
comes a moment when you know you're
going to get some sort of call but you
don't know what the man on the other end
of the line is going to say it is
excruciating there is no other way to
describe it first of all my close
friends will tell you that I never
believed that it would happen because
you know for all kinds of reasons that
this would not come to pass so I had
gotten a call in New York first from
Erskine Bowles who at that stage was the
chief of staff and he said to me if the
president were to call you tomorrow
morning and if he were to ask you to be
Secretary of State what would you say
and I thought is there anybody in the
world who would say no so i said i'll be
there and of course i'd say yes so then
we quickly elaine choke us who is my
chief of staff we flew down to
Washington and she spent the night at my
house because we were all too panicked
to be a part and then we SAT there in
the morning in pink bathrobes afraid to
take a shower
for fair we would miss a phone call and
being president clinton the phone call
was much later than i had expected and
then the phone and I kept saying to
Elaine he's chickened out it's not going
to happen this is never going to be and
then I get the phone call and they put
me on hold and you know I just it was
not a good scene so when he did get on
the phone the first words were I want
you to be my secretary of state and that
was the first time I believe that it
really had happened and did you hesitate
that you give it that little half second
like I was ready to save her hahaha no I
did say what I really felt that I would
be honored to and that I would work very
hard never to disappoint him by the way
why is he always late you said it was
later than you expected and as someone
who covered him in his second term for a
while he was always late well I think
that the reason is because he gets so
involved with whatever he's doing I've
been in enough meetings with him to know
that there would be conversations with a
foreign leader or with our group and he
would be asking one question after
another and listening and kind of lost
track of time and people would come in
poke their head in the door and say the
next person is out there and he'd say
yeah and then we just keep talking
because he really loves the issues and
got very involved in them but you were
always on time yes although it was very
hard to be late for a meeting at the
White House all right your secretary of
state now you enter the building you go
to the eighth floor of you're the first
woman there you were welcomed by the old
boys club um not as much as I thought
actually I thought that once I had
become secretary of state that some of
the questions about whether a woman
could do it or whether there I was
capable of it that they'd go away but
bureaucracies are bureaucracies and I
think there continued to be questions
one of the things am that had happened
when people were thinking I couldn't be
Secretary was that they would say well
she can't D a woman can't deal with
foreign leaders and
certainly can't deal with the more
conservative Arab societies and what I
found was that it didn't have trouble
with that I had helped i arrived in a
very large plane that said United States
of America but they knew that when they
want to talk to the US they had to talk
to me but I did have a little bit more
trouble with some of the men in our own
government not because they were not
friends or that they were unkind but I
think they'd seen me in so many other
roles before Senate staffer somebody who
gave dinners was in you know the carpool
mom or knew their wife and and I think
that they found a little hard to believe
that all of a sudden I had gotten the
best job in foreign policy well you talk
in the book briefly about something I a
man I think it's remarkable your
relationship with him senator Jesse
Helms the Scourge when he was in the
Senate of the State Department always
withholding money from the department
from the UN and yet he loved you it was
a very unusual relationship and it
started in an unusual way because when I
was ambassador to the UN one of the
things about Senator Helms was that he
always did his own constituency work and
he called me up and he said you have
been asked to come and speak at a
college in north carolina and i would
like you to do it and i thought i was
getting out of it by saying yes i'll do
it if you do it with me and he called
back he said I've cleared my schedule
we're going down there together and so
one of the things I'm sure you've
learned is when somebody invites you to
speak and they introduce you they're not
about to say this is somebody I really
hate who doesn't know what she's doing
working for an organization that doesn't
operate so he gave me a very good
introduction and then I had an
opportunity to talk about why i liked
the UN right in front of him and he
liked my honesty and when i became
secretary he said as Madeline we are
going to make history together and we
did was thanks to his cooperation that
NATO expansion took place that was
probably the only issue we agreed on but
he was and
is a very courtly gentleman and he gave
me every opportunity to do my job let's
talk about some of the issues you had to
deal with and in foreign policy it's
always a crisis let's talk about Kosovo
the decision to enter the fray there to
go in to put the United States in line
how was that made well it was a long
decision or complicated and when I was
ambassador at the UN I had felt that it
took us too long to get into Bosnia I
was not happy with the way that had
preceded and I could see that ethnic
cleansing was in fact taking place in
Kosovo and then I and I was Secretary of
State and so I felt that I should use
whatever power that office held to bring
about an American intervention there and
if there were long discussions within
our principals group but President
Clinton agreed and that obviously was
key and so we pursued the issue and at
the same time made sure that we had our
friends and allies with us there are a
lot of people who say why didn't you go
to the UN and what happened on Iraq is
exactly the same but it wasn't because
we did get consensus from the 19 members
of NATO to have a military operation in
Kosovo and had that kind of
international support and it took an
incredible amount of work which I
described at some length I I do take
credit for one thing which is inventing
the diplomatic conference call it's not
exactly brain surgery but in terms of
getting the Allies together I had daily
conversations with them and we worked
our way up to the war through the war
and in the post-war period and so we
went into that with consensus from our
allies and I think that was very
important yes but you would be described
as a hawk on that here's their first
woman Secretary of State a member of a
Democratic administration and you're a
hawk well because I actually believe in
the goodness of American power when used
properly as a last resort not as a first
resort in combination with strong
diplomacy and I
the combination of using the threat of
the use of force in support of diplomacy
and then diplomacy in support of the use
of force I think brought us success in
Kosovo and while I do not think that
using force as the first and only resort
is right I think that there are times
when a principal foreign policy requires
it should more force have been used
against the Dom Hussein during the
Clinton administration you here today
the charge that Bill Clinton didn't pay
enough attention to it he could have
done something well that's absolutely
not true i mean we what happened when i
first got to the United Nations was all
those Security Council resolutions that
ended the war were in place and for four
years we kept the Alliance together in
support of the sanctions they began to
fray especially as the French and
Russians wanted to have commercial
contacts in Iraq we then decided that it
was essential to keep Saddam in his box
we bombed regularly in the no-fly zones
and if you remember those maps they
cover a very large proportion of Iraq we
never plan to invade i did call for
regime change but that was from an
internal uprising and i think we did
what we could and what we did was keep
him in his box and i believed that he
was a threat but not an imminent threat
and that we had taken the right steps do
you believe that weapons of mass
destruction in the chemical and
biological areas will indeed be found in
quantity in iraq today i'd be surprised
but i must say that i was willing to
believe that there were such weapons
before the war i'll tell you why because
when in 1998 the inspectors were kicked
out all the weapons had not yet been
accounted for by those inspectors and
and by the way the inspectors in the
years between 1991 and 1998 had managed
to destroy more weapons of mass
destruction than the first gulf war so i
thought they were doing their job and
some weapons were unaccounted for so
there was every reason to believe
that they still existed now I don't know
obviously where they are I think the
President Bush made a big mistake in
capitalizing on what I considered a
great victory which was to get the
inspectors back in and he should have
allowed them to continue to do their
work because it's my belief that
whatever weapons were there are not the
kind where you kick the door in and you
find some barrel of something but that
it requires very careful scientific work
in following the paper trail and that's
something the inspectors could do that
as wonderful as our military forces are
they are not trained to do that and what
concerns me now Sam is that those
weapons we don't know where they are and
that they may in fact either not exist
or be in the hands of some terrorists
how is this going to end President Bush
talks about wanting to establish a
democracy in Iraq which would then
spread throughout the Middle East can we
do that how long would it take well I do
think that in many ways the Middle East
is the biggest piece of unfinished work
that exists and I would very much like
to see democracy in the Middle East and
I'm chairman of the board of something
called the National Democratic Institute
that has people working in countries in
the Middle East to try to develop
democracy from the grassroots up by
virtue of its name you cannot impose
democracy democracy has to bubble up and
I think it will take a while and I hope
very much that that comes about I don't
think you can do it with a military
force but the polls say that Americans
are losing patience secretary Rumsfeld
said has only been four and a half
months when Americans continue to stay
the course as the administration said
well it depends on how many times they
change their explanation of what it is
we're doing there I think that it's very
hard two days ago the president said
that they had not linked to al-qaeda and
Osama bin Laden was said I'm saying I
must be crazy but I sure remember them
so
saying that and I think that there were
questions about you know was it the
weapons of mass destruction was it the
human rights issues so that's hard but I
hope very much that we stay the course
but not alone and that President Bush
has a huge opportunity now when he goes
to the United Nations to address the
General Assembly to get support for a
resolution that would internationalize
the political economic and humanitarian
part of the mission while leaving the
United States in charge of the military
mission with other countries I think if
we leave it now there is a chaotic
situation and what I'm not sure was true
before in that Saddam Hussein was
connected with terrorists I do think
that now Iraq has become a gathering
ground if not a breeding ground for
everybody who hates us you dealt with
the North Koreans personally yet today
many people say well it was the clinton
plan which fell apart gave the North
Koreans the opportunity to go forward
with their nuclear ambitions well again
I think that that is wrong what happened
let me say that I agree that Kim Jong Il
is one of the worst dictators around he
has made a very deliberate choice for
guns over butter his people are starving
and it is a fairly crazy place in terms
of just people being completely
propagandized but I believe that we were
on the track to try to get him to give
up his missile technology of his nuclear
programs were frozen as a result of the
agreed framework and we understood that
we were dealing with a very dangerous
dictator but we left a pretty good hand
of cards on the table that the Bush
administration did not pick up and one
of the things about Kim jong-il I don't
believe he's crazy I think he is onion
he is informed but isolated he's not
very good about reading messages and
it's even harder when the messages are
mixed none of the fun part perhaps the
most interesting part I don't ask the
students the audience here gets to ask
the questions first question please
reflect on the differences and
similarities between your department of
state and secretary Powell's I actually
think that they're not a lot of
differences because the State Department
is filled with very dedicated people
both Foreign Service officers and the
civil servants who who work there whose
major interest is to carry on the
diplomacy of the United States and I
think that they are people who care
deeply about what they do and are
underpaid and are now exposed to as many
dangers as our military are exposed to
the the diplomats are actually on the
front line so I don't think their
differences I have to say that when I
started writing my book I thought that
some of the problems I was having in the
interagency process was due to the fact
that I was a woman but in watching
secretary Powell I don't think that's
the issue anymore no it's endemic to the
job in the department how did you manage
to balance a very successful career and
raised three daughters well I there's
not an answer to that I they are take a
little credit go ahead well basically
they they actually had a good father we
worked together very well on that and
they have a very good work ethic and
they're they're just very good daughters
and we had our moments we now all read
just remember the good times but we had
a few fights but they really worked hard
and I think they understood the value of
determination and working they are great
great daughters and have produced with
their husbands six fabulous
grandchildren alright here's a question
everyone's asking today when do you
think we'll have our first woman
president that's the question and i'll
just add and will she be Hillary Rodham
Clinton well I have it's a question I
can't answer I hope very much that the
time comes
when there is a woman president and I am
sure that the first woman president will
have some of the same problems that I
had a secretary of state but that it is
will be shown that a woman can and will
be a very good president and I think
whenever she decides to do whatever she
decides to do that Hillary Clinton is a
remarkable leader do you think she'll
enter this year I have no idea do you
wanted to I had died you know I'm not
into timing I know when to give up to
questions and they're really one Madam
Secretary would you be willing to serve
in the next Democratic administration if
so what would be your post of choice
well um I have said many many times that
I loved public service more than
anything in the world and that being
Secretary of State was a great job and
that I never believed people who said
they were glad it was over but very
rarely do you get a second chance after
you've had a very large job but I
obviously would be willing to do
whatever I'm asked to do and i hope i
have along with a lot of people the
opportunity to do so do you miss it
absolutely that's why I don't believe
people who say they don't what could be
better than to represent the United
States at a time when we are or were
well-regarded and feel man you have an
opportunity to make a difference all
right you write about ariel sharon and
yasser arafat what do you think about
the current impasse in the Middle East
where do we go from here well I it's and
we only have about four hours down it's
a true tragedy and I again and i know
this becomes a recurring theme but there
are too many things that were part of
policy when we left office where it was
not picked up there was what we all call
ABC anything but clinton and i believe
that we left the Middle East peace talks
everybody was so sorry that our time and
run out because
President Clinton put a great deal of
time too into it and was working hard I
wish that the United States had stayed
involved in the Middle East peace
process and that in the last two and a
half years so many lives might not have
been lost but I'm glad that President
Bush and the team has put down the road
map we need to get back to it there
needs to be some accountability but let
me say this about our fought I spent
more time with him than I ever imagined
or wanted to I interrupt here that
delicious story that in Paris when he
wanted to leave you went running after
the automobile well it was all true has
the added benefit of being true we were
at talks there which were posted at Camp
David and we were working very hard and
President Chirac was playing his
normally helpful role and had called are
fought in order to have a meeting with
him which I thought was not particularly
good timing and our thought was also
getting a little tired of waiting as we
were negotiating with the Israelis and
so all of a sudden he decides to get up
and leave and I'm in another room and
one of my staffers comes and says he's
leaving and we were in the residents of
the American ambassador a beautiful
residents with a large cobblestone
courtyard and our fight is getting into
his car I'm running across it in my high
heels screaming shut the gates shut the
gates and they did good this you didn't
trip thank goodness and they did manage
to shut the gates a few seconds before
his car got out and I managed to
persuade him to come back in but he is a
very tough character as I said I spent
more time with him than I ever thought I
would and I know the following things
that he loves being a victim and for the
Israeli government to decide or some
people within it that it would be a good
idea to exile him or give him some other
way vice pray for Prime Minister of
Israel the other day suggested that one
option was to kill Arafat now the
government denounced
that option the next day yeah that's the
lucky thing but the bottom line here is
if you remember the pictures from two
days ago he's up in a window he's
blowing kisses and smiling and waving
and getting a lot of support from a lot
of people who I think we're tired of him
are all of a sudden supporting him so he
is at his best as a victim and I do
think that he was on the way to being
marginalized but by making hit by
deliberately saying they wouldn't deal
with him I think they have recreated him
in some way I don't think he's capable
of making the right decisions I think he
is an obstacle to the process he
certainly turned down the best deal that
ever was offered but I think isolating
him like this does not work this
questioner says I heard former President
Clinton speak in Sydney Australia last
year he commented that one of the
greatest regrets from his presidency was
that he had had the opportunity to get
bin Laden in 1998 but didn't take it
please give us your insights and
opinions in this matter well I didn't
hear the speech nor do I think that the
phrase was quite that but I do think
that we did try very hard in 1998 to get
bin Laden and what had happened was that
the my worst day as Secretary of State
was when our embassies blew up in kenya
and tanzania and we took immediate
action to retaliate by launching 75
cruise missiles against afghanistan and
osama bin laden's camp we almost got him
and hand grenades and horseshoes close
doesn't count I understand that and but
President couldn't put out an order for
lethal force to be used and if you
remember we also bombed a pharmaceutical
factory in Sudan which we knew to be
associated with some have bin Laden
producing bx you're convinced it was
produced in the VX gas their people to
this day say it was just a pharmacist no
I mean on the basis of intelligence that
we had I was convinced and people
thought we overreacted that was part of
it you know wag the dog so I think we
did everything we could
good and now there are eight thousand US
forces in Afghanistan we bombed them to
oblivion and they still can't find Osama
bin Laden so I think we did the best we
could with the intelligence that we had
at the time wag the dog it brings us to
Monica Lewinsky I was I was there the
day in the driveway it was raining when
you and three other cabinet members came
out and were asked not by me but another
questioner do you believe President
Clinton when he said he had no
relationship sexual relationship with
that woman and you said yes I believe
him well I did because we had had a
cabinet meeting in which he told us all
that it was not true and but he lied to
you that is true how do you feel about
that well I you know I don't feel good
about it and I think that what happened
was a great personal tragedy for
President Clinton and his family and it
is something that will that is
unfortunately tarnishing a president who
I think was brilliant and did a great
job and I think should go down in
history as one of the great presidents
and I was very proud to serve for him
did that interfere however with your
conduct in foreign policy matters no it
didn't actually and I think it's that's
a very important point to make because
President Clinton for whatever reason
has an ability to compartmentalize and
he spent a great deal of time with us on
foreign policy I never had any trouble
getting access to him or dealing with
him on foreign policy issues and if you
look at the calendar the truth is that
we spent a great deal of time on foreign
policy during 1998 for instance the Y
talks with the Israelis and the
Palestinians took place then he was
completely focused the other part Sam is
that foreigners thought we were crazy
that this was a subject that constantly
went on some of your colleagues insisted
on always asking questions about it no
matter where we were and if
you remember just there was a general
assembly session during this time
President Clinton came to speak he got a
standing ovation from the delegates
which doesn't happen except for Nelson
Mandela and in fact it was a sign of
them trying to show their respect for
him if the Constitution were ever
amended to allow foreign born members of
our country to be President would you
consider running that is one of those
questions that I answer with my favorite
hypothetical if my mother had wheels
she'd be a bicycle is it true that
President Havel suggested the youth
perhaps you wanted to return to the
Czech Republic and run for president
there he did actually and that was
really a great honor one because I have
the highest respect and affection for
president hovel and there is something
very wonderful about being asked to run
for president of the place where you
were born but I don't think it's right
because one I am an American and two I
didn't grow up and grow go through all
the terrible things that they all did
and so I'm happy to you know I'm very I
love visiting the castle is awful nice
but I really I'm an American all right
here is a question I don't know who I
don't know this case but I assume you do
and I've just have to find it the
question who wants to know about what he
or she calls the greatest civil rights
action in history Hartman vs. Madeleine
Albright's at the State Department I
don't know about that I don't know about
it either nor if I did what I comment
all right we'll just move forward their
richest move right ahead we've talked
about Iraq quite a bit you just
mentioned that you wouldn't go back to
Czechoslovakia because after all you
weren't there and had all the experience
of people there what about the fact that
we seem to be turning over to the new
administration in Iraq the running of
that provisional Council to
people who were exiles they were on the
outside rather than people who were
indigenous in Iraq during the period of
Saddam Hussein I think one of the
hardest questions is to and this is a
general kind of a general question is
how do people that are in exile relate
to people that have actually gone
through whatever whether it was the
Second World War these were questions
when the government in Poland was set up
or the government in the in
Czechoslovakia and clearly there are
highly qualified people that go into
exile and continue to work on behalf of
their country and what is important is
some kind of a mix of people who have
had experience with those who have been
there through the suffering but the
hardest part Sam and I try to write
about this is how you figure out who is
good and who is bad who cooperated with
whatever the totalitarian regime is how
did they behave did people denounce each
other one of the really hard parts in
Czechoslovakia when the police files
were opened up was the people who
thought that they were do you had that
had had relationships with their best
friend they then found out that person
was a stoolie and so that I think is the
hardest part as you put together
governments after a dictator has been
running it in your opinion has
international law with respect to
foreign policy us lost its relevancy
especially as the US rule as global
policeman has increased I think that
this administration has tried to make it
lose its relevancy I believe that the
United States which is a country of the
rule of laws operates better and would
be more comfortable if the international
legal system works also it needs work
and it needs evolution and development I
think that in establishing the war
crimes tribunal we took a great step
forward and I'm very glad that militia
vich is in The Hague going through a
trial I believed in the International
Criminal Court it needed a lot of work
on it and I do believe that
u.s. is an exceptional country but it
doesn't mean that we are totally apart
from laws and that we don't gain if
there is an international legal system
if Saddam Hussein should be captured she
to be tried by international court
should Iraqis that try him should we try
it well I was we actually while I was at
the UN we tried very hard to see whether
we could create some kind of a war
crimes commission that would deal with
Saddam Hussein and if the local court
cannot deal with him I would think that
a war crimes tribunal would be a good
idea but it would mean that the United
States would actually have to believe in
it what's your opinion on the split of
Czechoslovakia do you think that it was
the right step to do it well I often i
asked used to ask my father whether we
were checks or slow box and he said
you're a Czechoslovak and I grew up as a
Czechoslovakian Czechoslovakia I was
very unhappy when it split I thought it
was a mistake but in my recent
conversations with both Czechs and
Slovaks I have found that they think
they have a much better relationship now
than they had before and that they
actually cooperate okay we moved to
China how do you think the United States
should deal with China today I think
China is our biggest challenge because
it is a growing regional as well as
global power and it is obviously
complicated in that we don't agree with
their human rights positions and we
believe that they can be a force for
good but are concerned about how they
operate I'm very glad we brought them
into the World Trade Organization I
think I was very troubled at the
beginning of the Bush administration
when they seem to be creating or
recreating an enemy and I'm glad that
they are dealing with China now but it
is a what we used to call a
multi-faceted relationship and you have
to be able to be very clear about their
human rights record and at the same time
understand that cooperating with them is
very important on security issues you've
received the day when communism will
fall in China
and another form of government will take
its place well I think that they are
discovering the great foibles of
communism and have developed some
entrepreneurial system that operates
within it and I have always believed
that communism is losing ideology and
that we are all the same and that the
Chinese people would just as everybody
else like to make decisions about their
own lives and this question and what you
notice skip to the to the former Soviet
Union and women what do you see as the
biggest challenge for women in the
former Soviet Union well one of the
interesting things was you know the
communist ideology always said that it
had liberated women that is true they
liberated them to work four times as
hard as the men and they I spent a lot
of time in doing surveys and things
about women and former communist
countries and I think they really felt
that they had not had an opportunity to
have normal lives of any kind and
interestingly enough many of the Soviet
era women then then were Russians or
another nationalities wanted to go and
have a normal life they wanted to be
married they wanted to have children
they they wanted to be able to have jobs
of their choice and so I think those
continue to be their challenges high
time is drawn to a close but I've got to
ask you about your famous hats when you
were secretary of state you were always
wearing a different large often floppy
hat you still do that I do I try not to
look like a mushroom but I do like to
wear hats and the reason it all started
was my daughter picked us up because I
got off a plane on my first trips i love
Stetsons and so I had one and she said
mom I know why you're doing this your
hair was a mess when you woke up in the
morning on that airplane and she was
absolutely right but then it kind of
became a standard and people wanted to
know why I wasn't wearing a hat so the
combination of what kind of pin I was
wearing and what kind of hat I was
wearing goes back to your first question
which is I didn't want to be boring a
secretary of state and you never were
and when it comes to a bed
hair day I sit with that I know exactly
how you feel secretary Madeleine
Albright thank you very much for being
with us
Madam Secretary is published by miramax
books an imprint of Hyperion visit
Hyperion Books com for more information